في اخر تطورات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
تحولت الانظار الى المعركه الدائره في
البحر الاسود حيث نجحت كييف في استخدام
سلاح مسيرات البحريه ضد تهديدات الروسيه
للسفن بعد انسحاب موسكو من اتفاق تصدير
الحبوب عبر البحر الاسود وقالت الوكاله
الفيدراليه الروسيه للنقل البحري ان
الناقل الروسيه اس اي جي تعرضت لهجوم
بزورق مسير قرب شبه جزيره القرمه تسبب في
حدوث ثقب في غرفه المحركات على جانب
الناقل الايمن من جهته قال مصدر استخباري
نقلاني ان زورقا مسيرا يحمل 450 كيلو جرام
من المتفجرات ضرب ناقله نفط تحمل وقودا
للقوه الروسيه في اعلن حاكم المدينه
بالقرب من مدينه سيفاستوبول واشار على
صفحته في تيليجرام الى اتخاذ الاجراءات
اللازمه لتدمير الثوره